One of the things psychologists have
done for the last 20 years,
especially the social psychologist,
is pushed this idea of self esteem.
You should feel good about yourself and
I think,
why would you tell someone 20 that?
It's like,
you should feel good about who you are.
no,
you shouldn't.
Why should you feel good about who you
are?
It's like you should feel good about who
you could be.
That's way better because you got 60
years to turn into who you could wait a
minute.
Are you what your accomplishments are or
you descend dividual going through this
journey.
I mean I don't think there's anything
wrong with feeling good about who you
are as long as it's tempered by an
understanding of potential and what you
have accomplished versus what you can
accomplish,
but having confidence big,
hard.
It is.
It is,
and I'm not saying that people shouldn't
have confidence,
but like often you take young people say
there are 16 to 22 and they're not
really feeling that good about who they
are because their life is chaotic and in
disorder and they don't know where
they're going and they don't know which
way is up a call,
so that could be bad parenting card.
Yes,
a lot of abuse going on and I think
that's one of the reasons why that
resonates with people.
This idea of be happy for you about who
you are,
feel good about who you are,
but.
But the thing is it has to be stated
with precision.
It's like,
yes,
it's like you should.
You should treat yourself as if you're
valuable,
especially in potential,
but you should concentrate on who you
should become,
especially if you're young.
And so let's say you're miserable and
nihilistic and chaotic and depressed and
all of that now,
and you have your reasons,
you know,
terrible parenting abuse,
all of those things.
It's like,
well,
you should feel good about yourself.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
It's not the right message is that it's
more like you should understand how much
potential there is within you to set
that straight and then you should do
everything you can to manifest that in
the world and it will set it straight
and that's better than self esteem.
It's like you're.
You're in a crooked,
horrible position.
Okay,
fine.
There's a lot of suffering and pain
associated with that.
Yeah,
you can't just feel good about that
because it's not good,
but you can do something about it.
You can genuinely do something about it.
And I think all the evidence suggests
that that's the case.
Yes.
So I'm telling,
telling young people,
look,
there's no matter how bad your situation
is,
I'm not going to pretend it's okay.
It's not okay.
It's tragic.
Tainted with malevolence,
and some people really get hurt by
malevolent people like you know,
terribly hurt.
Sometimes they never recover.
It's really awful,
but there's more to you than you think.
And if you stand up and face it with a
positive,
with a,
with a noble vision,
with discipline and intent,
you can go far farther to overcoming it.
Then you can imagine,
and that's the principal upon which you
should predicate your behavior and I
think that one of the things that's
really nice about being a clinical
psychologist is that this isn't just
guesswork.
Like one of the things we know,
two things in clinical psychology,
one is truthful conversations redeemed
people because if you come to a clinical
psychologist who's worth his salt,
you'll have a truthful conversation.
The conversation is,
well,
what's wrong with my life and here's
what caused it,
you know,
maybe it takes a year to have that
conversation and both of the
participants are doing everything they
can to lay it out properly.
Here's how it might be fixed,
here's what a beneficial future might
look like.
And so it's a completely honest
conversation if it's working well and
all that's happening in the conversation
is that the two people involved are
trying to make things better.
That's the goal.
Let's see if we can have a conversation
that will make things better.
Okay?
So we know that works.
It does make things better.
And then another thing we know is that,
well,
let's say there's a bunch of things that
you're afraid of that are in your way,
so you have some vision about who you
want to be.
Maybe you have to,
you know,
you want to be successful in your
career,
so you have to learn to talk in front of
a group.
It's like,
okay,
well you're afraid of that,
so no wonder you don't want to be
humiliated.
So okay,
so what do we do about that?
Well,
maybe we first get you to speak in front
of one person and then three people you
know for five minutes and then for 10
minutes,
like graduated exposure to what you're
afraid of,
voluntary graduated exposure to what
you're afraid of is curative.
And that's true.
It works.
The documentation is it.
It's how people learn.
So,
so to,
to,
to tell people that if you confront the
world forthrightly,
if you speak the truth and you expose
yourself courageously to those things
that you're afraid of,
that your life will improve.
And so will the life of people around
you like as far as I'm concerned,
that's as close to undeniable fact as
we've as we've got.
And it also dovetails nicely with the
underlying archetypal stories,
that heroic stories.
It's like,
go out there,
find the dragon confronted.
It's a dragon.
It might eat you.
It's dangerous,
but it's worse to cower at home and wait
for it to come and devour you.
Go out there confronted,
get the gold,
share it with the community.
It's like,
yeah,
it's the oldest story of mankind.